TERRIBLY LONG AGO, MIKE.
>> Mike: NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT.
KEVIN CORKE LIVE IN WEST
PALM BEACH, FLORIDA.
MANY THANKS.
STUNNING ADMISSION THE FBI
ADMITTING IT MISHANDLED A
TIP ABOUT 19-YEAR-OLD
NIKOLAS CRUZ.
ADMITTED TO MURDERING 17
PEOPLE AT A HIGH SCHOOL
EARLIER THIS WEEK.
SOMEONE WARNED THE BUREAU
LAST MONTH ABOUT WHAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN WEDNESDAY
AFTERNOON.
TIP FROM THE PUBLIC ABOUT
CRUZ THAT FAILED TO PREVENT
THE MASSACRE THAT REVELATION
COMES AS THE FUNERALS BEGIN
FOR SOME OF THE VICTIMS.
CORRESPONDENT PHIL KEATING
IS AT THE SHOOTING SCENE IN
PARKLAND, FLORIDA.
CASINO, PHIL.
>> GOOD EVENING, MIKE.
WARNING FLAGS WERE FLYING
HIGH AND FLYING FOR A VERY
LONG TIME.
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
1-YEAR-OLD FORMER STUDENT OF
STONE MAN DOUGLAS HIGH
SCHOOL BEHIND ME NOW ACCUSED
OF 17 COUNTS OF FIRST DEGREE
MURDER.
JUST ABOUT AN HOUR AGO,
BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF SAID
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS HIS
OFFICE RECEIVED 20 CALLS FOR
SERVICE, SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
CRUZ AND HIS BEHAVIOR AT THE
TIME.
HE SAYS SUCH CALLS FOR
FUTURE IN THE FUTURE WILL
NOW BE FAR MORE WELL
SCRUTINIZED?
ALSO AT THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TODAY A STUNNING
PUBLIC ADMISSION?
TWO.
>> DAYS AFTER THE WORST HIGH
SCHOOL SHOOTING IN U.S.
HISTORY MASSACRE FBI WARNED
COULD HAPPEN THE AGENCY NOW
ADMITS IT FAILED TO PROPERLY
HANDLE A JANUARY 5TH TIP
FROM A PERSON TO CRUZ ABOUT
GUN OWNERSHIP AND ALLEGED
DESIRE TO KILL PEOPLE.
SPECIFICALLY TO CARRY OUT A
SCHOOL SHOOTING FORWARD UP
POTENTIAL LIFE TO THE FIELD
OFFICE.
IT WAS NOT.
FIVE WEEKS LATER 17 STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS ARE DEAD.
>> ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND
OVER 1,000 EMPLOYEE HE IS OF
THE MIAMI FIELD OFFICE, WE
TRULY REGRET ANY ADDITIONAL
PAIN THAT THIS HAS CAUSED.
>> IN AN EQUALLY RARE SLAP
FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
HIS FBI.
JEFF SESSIONS RELEASED A
HIGHLY CRITICAL ADMONITION,
QUOTE:  IT IS NOW CLEAR THAT
THE WARNING SIGNS WERE THERE
AND TIPS TO THE FBI WERE
MISSED.
WE SEE THE TRAGIC
CONSEQUENCES OF THOSE
FAILURES.
AND FLORIDA GOVERNOR RICK
SCOTT TAKING THE OUTRAGE
EVEN FURTHER, QUOTE FBI'S
FAILURE TO TAKE ACTION
AGAINST THIS KILLER IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
17 INNOCENT PEOPLE ARE DEAD
AND ACKNOWLEDGING A MISTAKE
ISN'T GOING TO CUT IT.
THE FBI DIRECTOR NEEDS TO
RESIGN.
IN SEPTEMBER THE FBI WAS
ABLE TO SOURCE SAME NAME AS
THE SUSPECT WRITING I'M
GOING TO BE A PROFESSIONAL
SCHOOL SHOOTER.
AND BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF
NOW CLARIFYING BROUGHT WITH
HIM.
>> THE CIRLTD NEVER WAS IN
POSSESSION OF A GAS MASK OR
ANY TYPE OF SMOKE GRENADES.
>> FORMER STUDENT EXPELLED
LAST YEAR FOR DISCIPLINARY
REASONS.
19-YEAR-OLD NIKOLAS CRUZ
REMAINS HELD WITHOUT BOND.
>> HE'S REMORSEFUL.
HE IS FULLY AWARE OF WHAT IS
GOING ON.
AND HE'S JUST A BROKEN HUMAN
BEING.
[CHANTING]
>> EMOTIONS AND POLITICS
CONTINUE TO DOMINATE THIS
AFFLUENT COMMUNITY WHILE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SCHOOLS
AND POLICE ARE DEALING WITH
COPYCAT THREATS.
MOST HAVE BEEN SOCIAL MEDIA
HOAXES.
THE DEVASTATION CAUSED BY
THE SHOOTING FOR THE
COMMUNITY LED SEVERAL
THOUSAND PEOPLE TO GATHER
TODAY THURSDAY NIGHT AT THE
PARKLAND AMPHITHEATER FOR
EMOTIONAL CANDLELIGHT VIGIL
THIS STUDENT LOST A CLOSE
FRIEND.
>> I THINK HE WOULD
APPRECIATE WHAT WE'RE DOING.
AND I THINK THAT PEOPLE
WOULD WANT TO REMEMBER IN A
POSITIVE WAY.
>> AND JUST OUT TONIGHT BY
THE FLORIDA SUN SENTINEL
QUOTING NIKOLAS CRUZ'S
PUBLIC DEFENDER, CRUZ IS NOW
AGREEING TO PLEAD GUILTY TO
FIRST DEGREE MURDER.
17 COUNTS OF THAT FOR
KILLING 14 STUDENTS, A
TEACHER, A HIGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL COACH, AND AN
ATHLETIC DIRECTOR.
ALL IN EXCHANGE FOR AVOIDING
THE DEATH PENALTY AND ALSO
THE FRESHMAN BUILDING, THE
THREE-STORY STRUCTURE ON
CAMPUS WHERE ALL OF THE
KILLINGS HAPPENED WILL NOW
BE DEMOLISHED SO THAT NONE
OF THE SURVIVING STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS WILL EVER HAVE
TO WALK PAST THOSE
CLASSROOMS OF CARNAGE AGAIN.